A form of nickname has been around since the
early 14th century- eke name, literally meaning
“an additional name.”
Eke is an even older word, dating back to
about 1200 meaning “to increase.”
(Eke also meant “to lengthen,” and it
was this meaning that eventually became the
meaning of to eke out or make just enough.)
The first documented instance of “eke name”
comes from the 1303 Middle English devotional
Handlyng Synne, by Robert Manning of Brunne.
In it, he states on line 1531 to 1534, “As
moche þan he ys to blame Þat ȝeueþ a man
a vyle ekename Ȝyf hys ryȝt name be withdrawe
Gostlychë…”
So how did we get “nickname” from “ekename”?
This is one of the numerous examples of metanalysis
or rebracketing.
In this case, “an ekename” became “a
nekename” and ultimately, today, “a nickname.”
We can see this transformation starting in
the 1440 work Promptorium Parvulorum (“Storehouse
for Children,” the first English to Latin
dictionary) by Geoffrey the Grammarian of
England, where it states “Neke name, or
eke name, agnomen.”
Similarly, the 1483 English to Latin dictionary
Catholicon Anglicum has an entry: “An Ekname,
agnomen.”
We see another incarnation of this in Sir
Thomas More’s Confutation of Tyndale’s
Answer published in 1532:
I shoulde here call Tindall by another name:‥it
were no nyck name at all and yet would there
some then say that it were not honest so to
do; and this will some such folk say as in
the villainous words of his spoken by this
blessed sacrament will find no fault at all.
But meseemeth surely that at the first hearing
of such a shameful word spoken by the mouth
of such a shameless heretic by this holy sacrament
of Christ, the whole Christian company present
should not be able to contain themselves from
calling him “knave” all with one voice
at once.
Fast-forwarding a bit to the 17th century,
we find several instances of the more modern
“nick-” spelling, such as in the 1617
Itinerary by Fynes Moryson, where it states,
“James Fitz-thomas‥was by a nicke-name
called the Suggon Earle…”
Within a century of this, “nick-name,”
“nick name,” and “nickname” became
relatively commonly used in place of older
variants and the original “eke name,”
with the latter being phased out completely.
A similar example of this type of rebracketing
can be seen in how we got “another” (and,
sometimes “nother” in such phrases as
“a whole nother”) from “an other.”
Or going the other way, how we got “apron”
from the original “napron” (“a napron”
being rebracketed to “an apron”) and “umpire”
from “noumpere” (“a noumpere” being
rebracketed to “an oumpere”).